- [Narrator] It's no secret
that millions of Americans
will lose health coverage under
Trumpcare but don't worry,
after weeks of secret
meetings Republican Senators
are proud to
announce a solution.
American Health Box.
Here's how it works.
Every month for less than
the cost of an iPhone we'll
mail you a box of new
and used medical supplies
right to your front door.
Pre-existing condition?
No sweat, if you eliminate
doctors and hospitals
and just treat yourself
it's amazing how
affordable your illness
can be and fun too.
Who needs Medicaid when you
have American Health Box?
And the best part of Health Box?
You'll never get bored.
We never repeat the
same prescription twice.
And for the ladies we've got
American Lady Health Box,
a Health Box designed for
the unique medical needs of a
woman as understood by our
oldest, whitest male Senators.
Sign up today and make
sure to use promo code,
poverty is a choice to
get your first month free.
- [Both] Thank you
American Health Box.
- Thank you American Health Box.
- [Narrator] Oh thank
you American Health Box.
American Health Box.
It's the best...
...we could come up with.